[Music]
sometimes fate is like a small sandstorm
that keeps changing directions you
change direction but the sandstorm
chases you
you turn again but the storm adjusts
over and over you play this out like
some ominous dance with death just
before dawn why because this storm isn't
something that flew in from far away
this storm is you something inside of
you this quote from the first chapter of
Haruki Murakami's Kafka on the shore
captures the teenage protagonists
turmoil desperate to escape his
tyrannical father and the family curse
he feels doomed to repeat he renames
himself Kafka after his favorite author
and runs away from home but memories of
a missing mother along with the dreams
that haunt his waking life proved more
difficult to outrun published in
Japanese in 2002 and translated into
English three years later Kafka on the
shore is an epic literary puzzle filled
with time-travel hidden histories and
magical underworlds readers delight in
discovering how the mind-bending imagery
whimsical characters and eerie
coincidences fit together
Kafka narrates every second chapter with
the rest centering on an old man named
Satoru Nakata after awakening from a
coma he went into during the Second
World War
Nakata loses the ability to read and
write but gains a mysterious neck for
talking to
when he's asked to tale a missing pet
he's thrown on to a dangerous path that
runs parallel to Kafka's soon prophecies
come true portals to different
dimensions open up and fish and leeches
begin raining from the sky but what ties
these two characters together and is it
a force either one of them can control
the collision of different worlds is a
common thread in Haruki Murakami's work
his novels and short stories often forge
fantastic connections between personal
experience supernatural possibilities
and Japanese history born in Kyoto in
1949 Murakami grew up during the
post-world War two American occupation
of Japan the shadow of war hung over his
life as it does his fiction Kafka on the
shore features biological attacks
military ghosts and shady conspiracies
Murakami's work blurs historical periods
and draws from multiple cultural
traditions references to Western society
and Japanese customs and tumble over
each other from literature in fashion to
food and ghost stories he has a penchant
for musical references - especially in
Kafka on the shore as the runaway Kafka
wanders the streets of a strange city
led zepplin and prints keep him company
soon he takes refuge in an exquisite
private library while he spends his days
poring over old books and contemplating
a strange painting and the library's
mysterious owner he also befriends the
librarian who introduces him to
classical music like Schubert this
musical sensibility makes Murakami's
work all the more hypnotic he frequently
bends the line between reality and a
world of dreams and is considered a
master of magic lurking in the mundane
this is a key feature of magical realism
in contrast to fantasy magic in this
sort of writing rarely offers a way out
of a problem instead it becomes just one
more thing that complicates life in
Kafka on the shore characters are faced
with endless otherworldly distractions
from a lovesick ghost to a flute made
from cat Souls these challenges offer no
easy answers instead they leave us
marveling at the resourcefulness of the
human spirit to deal with the unexpected
while Kafka often seems suspended in
strangeness there's a tenderness and
integrity at the heart of his mission
that keeps him moving forward gradually
he comes to accept his inner confusion
in the end his experience echoes the
readers the deeper you go the more you
find from one Kafka to another ever
wonder what the word Kafka esque
actually means find out for yourself
with this video
[Music]